und jetzt möchte ich mit alexanders die
vans sprechen er ist der rechtsanwalt
und hat sich auf das sexualstrafrecht
spezialisiert herr stephens schönen
guten abend herr stevens warum haben sie
sich ausgerechnet der sexualstrafrecht
ausgesucht warum verteidigen sie solche
sexualstraftäter zum einen bin ich der
meinung dass man hier nicht die
verzierung strafverteidiger lehnten
beide ja egal ob opfer als auch täter
hat ein recht auf die bestmögliche
verteidigung
das ist in einem rechtsstaat nun mal so
und zum anderen davon auch nicht
vergessen so dramatisch und tragisch
diese fälle jetzt sind die zutage
getreten sind
es gibt leider sehr sehr viele
trittbrettfahrer in dem bereich es gibt
verschiedene statistiken die bis zu 50
prozent falsch anzeigen ausgehen das ist
immer dann der fall wenn es bei
scheidungs kriegen und
familienstreitigkeiten zu problemen
kommt man meistens männer verdächtigt
und ja und dann eben die leidtragenden
so oder so die kinder sind aber in einem
so schweren fall wenigen gerade gehört
haben was ja was macht das mit ihnen
persönlich wie gehen sie mit solchen
fällen um
naja es ist immer die gratwanderung zum
einen muss man sagen dass es im
sexualstrafrecht das sittliche moralisch
auf tiefster stufe steht nie so etwas
wie ein geständnis gibt das ist ganz
ganz selten das heißt sie wissen als
strafverteidiger oft überhaupt nicht
sagt dieser mann die wahrheit ist das so
passiert oder spielen da andere gründe
eine rolle in dem fall scheint es ja
doch relativ offensichtlich zu sein
wenngleich auch hier natürlich die
unschuldsvermutung gilt
nichtsdestotrotz da ganz klar sagen das
geht auch einem als verteidiger nahe
also wenn sie fest felsenfest von der
schuld ihres mandanten überzeugt sind
ist das schon sehr schwierig empfinden
sie dann ab oder empfinden sie
vielleicht auch empathie oder sympathie
wer also empathie kann man mit jemandem
den mann für schuldig hält sicherlich
nicht mehr empfinden vor allem ich bei
so schrecklichen taten nichts desto
trotz ist es mein job man muss sich da
auch ein stück weit distanzieren und da
geht es mir wahrscheinlich wie vielen
anderen auch die diesen job machen
auch auf der anderen seite ja man muss
ja an die
kriminalkommissare denken die auch diese
fielen daten auswerten müssen die
staatsanwälte und die richter und eben
aber auch die strafverteidiger wir alle
müssen uns distanzieren und müssen da
einfach unseren job machen so hart das
jetzt klingt zeigen diese täter denn
bestimmte muster kann man sie irgendwie
erkennen meint ist es ganz schwierig
also man kann vielleicht feststellen
das sage ich aber jetzt nicht aus einer
empirischen studie heraus sondern
einfach aus zehn jahren erfahrung dass
gerade beim sexuellen missbrauch von
jungen es ganz oft der fall ist dass
sich die täter in einem gewissen milieu
bewegen
oftmals sind es ausbilder trainer
erzieher und so weiter also sie zeigen
keine verhaltensmuster in dem sinne
sondern eher berufliche muster ohne aber
da jetzt konkret allen erzieherin dazu
nahe zu treten aber es ist leider so da
wo sie einen fußballverein mit lauter
jungs haben einen jungen internat und so
weiter man kennt ja die fälle da ist
quasi ein magnet gegeben
ja für pädophile finden sie denn auch
dass wir härtere strafen brauchen
nein da bin ich tatsächlich entschieden
dagegen
denn hier würden wir immer sehr gern von
der politik polarisiert wir haben für
den sexuellen missbrauch von kindern die
härteste strafe die es gibt das sind bis
zu 15 jahre freiheitsstrafe
denken sie an den mörder der krieg zwar
lebenslänglich aber in der regel nach 15
jahren bewährung also sie sind auf
ähnlichen stufen sie können höchstens
von der justiz fordern dass sie härter
urteilen aber auch da kann ich in einer
aus der erfahrung sagen wenn sie an den
richter haben der selbst kinder hat der
wirt keine sexualstraftäter und erst
recht niemand der kinder schwer sexuell
missbraucht irgendwie lapidar davor
davonkommen lassen die strafen
vor allem jetzt auch durch die weitere
aufklärung die befinden sich alle
jenseits der zehn jahre aber wie kann es
sein wenn sie sagen kein richter wird
jemanden lapidar davonkommen lassen wie
kann es dann in so einem fall kommen er
war ja schon vorbestraft wegen sexuellen
missbrauchs an kindern und das mit nur
17 jahren
ja da muss man leider oder vielleicht
auch gott sei dank differenzieren es
macht natürlich einen unterschied ob sie
als minderjähriger eine straftat begehen
oder als volljähriger das wird auch
sicherlich ohne die akten jetzt zu
kennen hier der grund gewesen sein
sie können einen einen unter 18 jährigen
nur sehr schwer des schweren sexuellen
missbrauchs verurteilen denn da gibt es
eine regelung die besagt dass kinder bis
zu einem alter oder jugendliche bis zu
einem alter von 18 jahren ja selbst noch
nicht sexuell so ausgereift sind dass
sie das ganze auch verstehen und
bestraft die dann entsprechend milde
nichtsdestotrotz kann man auch da bis zu
zehn jahren haft bekommen aber ist das
system dann nicht falsch also dass man
schon so früh vielleicht sogar schon so
neigung erkennen und dann nicht
entschieden gehandelt wird
gerade in der wirkungsweise der
jugendlichen ist es sehr sehr schwierig
das zu erkennen und nicht doch darauf zu
hoffen dass sich vielleicht da ja gerade
bei den jugendlichen da eine geistige
reife entwickelt dass das natürlich
straftaten sind die auf sittlich
tiefster stufe stehen und in der
hoffnung dass das nicht wieder passiert
aber da geraten strafrichter
staatsanwälte aber auch die
psychiatrischen sachverständigen einfach
an ihre grenzen vor allem dann wenn
solche straftaten im jugendalter
begangen werden was keine seltenheit ist
danke schön herr stephens für das
gespräch